what do you think Andrew Tate has
evolved in the most we've covered Andrew
Tate a lot what are your what's your
opinion um I mean I think he's a a
person who is a strong voice he's a good
influence um I think he's also giving
advice uh through life experience you
know you kind of see him kind of change
perspectives in certain areas but that
comes with you know different
perspectives you know he was in a prison
cell like you don't know what goes
through your mind during those times and
maybe you value different things so I
can admire that he's firm in some things
but I can also admire like new
information as you may refer to um he
adjusts and and and shares his
experience I think that's also keeps
that authentic uh human uh person you
know it keeps them like a what's the
word I'm looking for um human human
isn't keeping it real keeping it real